another big event coming to las vegas
the nfl draft about three weeks away and
we have just learned about some major
road closures that are going to impact
nearly all of us lane reductions are
going to start as early as wednesday
april 13th and then run all the way
through may 6 24 hours a day this is
mainly right in the heart of the strip
between flamingo and the boulevard now
on flamingo the right-hand turn lane to
turn onto the boulevard that's going to
be closed then a second lane is going to
be closed from six in the morning until
five in the evening that's going to
happen every single day closer look now
roads completely shut down this starts
wednesday the 27th for the draft through
that sunday the 30th las vegas boulevard
completely shut down in both directions
from flamingo out to the bellagio
hundreds of thousands of fans and
pedestrians are going to flood all these
streets here you see and then we'll have
a lot more details and some alternate
routes for you for the nfl draft on our
website at 8newsnow.com